the original vampiric creature of
australian mythology
the yarma yahoo stands out due to its
unusual appearance
and interesting feeding habits small in
stature the red skinned monsters other
notable feature is its
giant mouth though it may look silly
these beings give a
whole new meaning to the word
bloodsucker
meant to frighten children into good
behavior it also ties the members of
indigenous communities to one another
to their environment and to their shared
past oh and
by the way they drink your blood through
their fingertips
and their toes i'm dr emily zarka
and this is monstrum one of mythology's
truly unique creatures
the australian yaramayahu's unassuming
almost
comical appearance hides its threatening
nature
standing only about four feet tall the
red skinned monster has a
massive serpentine head on a
disproportionately small body
its mouth throat and stomach are
likewise freakishly large
this strange being has no teeth no
weapons to speak of
so why is it so scary well first of all
it swallows its food whole
its mouth widens like a snake much wider
than its body size
the better to gobble up its prey and
what is its prey
us or more accurately it is coming for
your children the lore surrounding the
yarma yahoo functioned primarily to
frighten aboriginal children into
obedience
so that they wouldn't wander away from
the safety of their homes and into the
bush
the australian outback is a notoriously
unforgiving landscape
and you can't blame a community for
developing particularly gruesome
and terrifying stories to keep their
kids in line
although it won't turn down an
unassuming adult either
i mentioned that this monster doesn't
appear to have any weapons but
appearances can be deceiving
especially when we're talking about this
diminutive fellow
in fact the yarma yahoo has two grisly
weapons to employ
sucker cup laden appendages and
regurgitation
according to one folk tale a man tired
from hunting
fell asleep under a tree before he could
even utter a sound
a yarma yahoo left upon him and sucked
his blood
with its fingers and toes the monster
began
to swallow him whole creeping over his
body with its mouth unnaturally wide
the hunter's mother saw what was
happening and grabbed her husband's
spear
but she was too far away and before she
could come close to the monster
the yarma yahoo stood and ran off to a
watering hole
his new victim in his stomach while
telling the tale to little children in
her community
the mother lamented the yarma yahoo must
have vomited him back up
a smart man she instructed would have
played dead until dark when the monster
was asleep and it was safer to flee
her son she believes tried to escape but
the monster caught him
only to swallow him up again and again
until he became like the monster himself
he had turned into a yarma yahoo
living among the thick leafy foliage of
wild fig trees
yarmayahu will pounce on its prey men
women
and children alike as they walk below or
are foolish enough to seek respite under
the tree's branches
fear of this creature was so great that
people would go out of their way to look
for shelter in caves
or rocky overhangs rather than sit under
a tree
the yarma yahoo's fingers and toes each
end in a cup shaped sucker like those of
an octopus
but these suckers drain their victim's
blood
and it gets worse yarma yahoo drains
just enough blood from its victims to
incapacitate them
then like a cat with a mouse the games
begin once the victim is unconscious
the yarma yahoo crawls toward it and
swallows the body whole
head first this apparently takes
considerable energy
requiring the monster to take a long
drink of water and then curl up for a
nap
the victim's still alive in its belly
upon waking the yarma yahoo vomits up
its presumably terrified meal and it
gets
weirder only once the creature falls
asleep again
it clearly has a thing for naps its
victim can run away
and if the yarma yahoo wakes the victim
may be safe since the monster cannot run
very fast
its gate resembling that of a cockatoo
but
you knew there was going to be a butt
didn't you it's not just the loss of
blood that the human prey must fear
if a person is caught by the yarma yahoo
more than once
they will become shorter and shorter
each time it regurgitates them
until they become as small as the
monster itself
slowly their skin will turn smooth and
red and they will lose
all of the hair on their body eventually
they become
a yarmayahu that's the creature
hauntingly creepy and yet surprisingly
practical from a community organization
standpoint
right but i mentioned earlier that this
monster story is
deeper than just a warning to kids about
the dangers of the wilderness that
surrounded them
like many of the monsters i explore
yarma yahoo's story is intrinsically
tied both to the cultural identity
and to the history of the people who
mythologized it the pervasive mythology
of the indigenous peoples of australia
reflects their deep ties to the land and
the environment
as well as the far-reaching effects of
colonialism on these cultures
aboriginal communities recognize three
important categories outside of humans
and animals in their mythos
ancestral creators ghosts or human
spirits
and spirit beings the ancestral creators
occupied the land during what the
aboriginals called dream time
the beginning of time they shaped the
entire world from sky to sea and
everything in between
they dictated the traditions and customs
of social and religious practice
for aboriginals humans exist because of
these ancestor beings
ghosts or human spirits are understood
to be the spiritual remains of the
living
finally there are the spirit beings
unlike the ancestral creators who are
beings from a time long ago
spirit beings exist in the here and now
living on the land alongside humans
aboriginal sacred beliefs see these
creatures including the yarma yahoo
as co-residents of a shared landscape
the spear beans are part of the physical
environment
and that they contribute in ways that
may directly influence the lives of
people
among these spirit beings is a whole
category of little men
or spirit men a group to which the
yarama yahoo belong
anthropologist philip a clark explored
this classification deeply
according to him these small beings with
human-like characteristics
unusually colored skin most commonly
read and a mischievous nature
are often connected to a particular
environment or locale
these spirit men are predominant in
myths among southeastern australian
aboriginals
that being said there is striking
differentiation and variation
in their appearance and habits across
communities and even within a single
community
moreover there are other little men who
appear throughout australian war
in western australia the yarma yahoo's
counterpart
looks more like an orangutan or a monkey
and has a hairy
but still red body in fact one thing
almost all the stories have in common
is the unusual coloring of the little
men they could be yellow green
gray white or red like our friend the
yarmouyahu
the broader group of these little men
generally live on high ground
whether it be on the tops of cliffs
hills or sand dunes
most active at dawn and dusk they are
spotted either in pairs or alone
hunters would leave out offerings from
their kills to appease these beings
of course there are ways in which yarma
yahoo tales differ from those of these
other spirit men
they are not reported in pairs and they
do most of their hunting during the day
they are truly unique however in that
they alone threatened to make you one of
their kind
before the british forcibly settled on
the continent over 500 indigenous groups
occupied the land many of their myths
and stories were misinterpreted by the
europeans
and creatures from aboriginal mythology
were regarded as
real foreign species by european
colonizers
beings that they had yet to see in the
wild but were certain
existed like the bunyip and even to a
degree
the yarma yahoo early 20th century
anthropologist and archaeologist
norman b tyndale believed that accounts
of the spirit men or
little folk were actually the diluted
oral history of a race of pygmy people
believed to have arrived in australia
more than 30 000 years ago the
increasing exchange of cultural
practices and folklore in post-colonial
australia
meant that indigenous myths were forever
altered including the mythology
describing its monsters
this helps explain for example why the
yarma yahoo is more often classified as
a vampire species in modern times
rather than as the spirit being it
originally was understood to be
it also helps us understand why we see
such variations in the monstrous traits
across cultures and throughout modern
history still
reported sightings of various diminutive
humanoid beings in australia
continued well into the 1980s and
folklore of the spirit men
continues to be shared among members of
indigenous communities today
the continuation of the oral traditions
of spirit beings by the aboriginal
people
serves as a connection to their regional
communities and is part of a larger
cultural
identity in post-colonial australia the
yarma yahoo might be a strange body
but it is nonetheless a body of
knowledge
i'll do it again i have an existential
crisis every time i swear
how quirky don't look at me